so some of you know i've been looking
for an assistant for a little while and
i've been going through hundreds and
hundreds of applications
and i thought it'd be a good opportunity
for me to share my thoughts on a
successful application
so in this video we're going to talk
about writing your resume and your cover
letter
and we're going to cover the basics like
structure and stuff like that
but more specifically i want to walk you
through the thought process and the
strategy behind writing your application
in a way that turns your weaknesses into
strengths
and your strengths into superpowers
so that you can get noticed in a sea of
applicants
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dani and i am
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver vc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and design and also some
tools and strategies that can help us
have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture so the process
of finding the right job can be
frustrating and confusing
which is why i've created a series where
i try to cover everything you need to
know when you're applying for an
architecture job
i'm going to leave links in the
description to my videos on how to build
your portfolio with free templates
how to put that portfolio online the
importance of having an online presence
and also some interview tips and how you
can talk about your work and your
experience so if you're applying for an
architecture drop of course your resume
should work in conjunction with your
portfolio to create a narrative of who
you are
so before you start with your resume
think about what story you want to tell
and how you want to sell yourself
because this is going to influence how
you craft your cover letter
and
how you describe your experience
and it's going to help you decide which
projects you want to show and
how to talk about those projects of
course every application should be
tailored to the firm you're applying for
but it works both ways
after skimming through the job postings
you might find that right off the bat
this job description doesn't really
align with your interest or your skill
sets so just skip right through those
and don't waste too much time on them
so first of all you need to spend a
little bit of time thinking about your
unique strengths and whether it's
applicable to this job posting
and
and the work they do and if you do find
some overlap then you can start
strategizing on how you want to sell
your skills i'm going to give you an
example with my own application at the
firm that i'm at currently but before
that a little bit about my background so
before this firm i've mostly worked on
small local projects like houses or
small commercial or office renaults and
i really wanted to work on bigger public
projects and i really wanted to work at
like an internationally recognized firm
where you see the work and you're like
okay that's really high quality work but
as an architect you get hired based on
your previous experience so when the
majority of your experience is one type
of work
it's good in one way because you build a
lot of expertise in that one type but
it's really hard to get your foot in the
door with other building types
so i really had to sit down and
strategize on how i could sell my
experience as an asset so i've tailored
this entire application to the firm that
i'm at now which is faulkner browns
architect
which is like a mid-sized international
firm
with its main office in the uk
but it also has a small firm
um in vancouver
in a sense that the partners started a
satellite office here in vancouver um
two or three years ago
so
while it has a reputation and the
projects of a large firm
it still has the resources of a small
startup firm
so
i'm thinking
they're
probably looking for people who can kind
of get down and dirty and
really help the firm like the local
office grow i'm really trying to sell
the story of this person who's not just
a great designer but someone who's like
practical and flexible and who can do a
variety of things
and someone who can contribute to the
firm culture and really help them build
a local reputation like i said i've
worked in small local firms for four
years before this which could be seen as
a downside because i haven't worked on
any big international project but i
really wanted to spend that as my asset
so in my cover letter i said having
focused my professional growth in a
small young firm over the last three
years i have become a nimble team player
and a proactive learner and can quickly
develop skills in any area that requires
assistance
i also mentioned some extra skills i've
picked up i've participated in marketing
and promotions
including proposal writing and
coordination
website design social media which is in
a small firm things that the partner or
the principal usually has to do
and so you're showing them that yeah you
can take away time from
from the principal's workload i also
talk about my presentation skills
in kind of direct relation to my youtube
channel which has been a great great
great asset for me professionally
because a lot of firms want to see
that
you're doing things on the side that
contribute to the field of architecture
and
it shows your passion it shows that you
have all of these soft skills that
that do come in really handy when you're
an architect but are not necessarily
taught in architecture school it also
shows that you can teach yourself skills
right
um and then i also talked a little bit
about business management
again talking about like working in a
small young firm i've learned the ins
and outs of managing an architectural
business um during my recent sabbatical
i worked as a freelance designer
recent sabbatical is when um
i i left my job
just before the pandemic started so i
had a window of time where i couldn't
find a job during that time i worked
as a freelance designer
where i was working on small-scale
projects for different small clients and
this experience helped me learn how to
negotiate fees and give proposals and
and i think just most importantly making
sure that the client is satisfied
because i know that these are all things
that
a small
new office
is gonna find really valuable from an
additional member
and then in my resume
i try to
reinforce this idea of this nimble
person
with like hands-on experience
and in the job description
under work experience section i
um i talk about how i work closely with
the firm principles on all aspects of
architectural projects
plus
these are things that typically an
intern
wouldn't really be asked to do in a big
firm
but it could be very valuable in a young
growing firm and then when we get into
my portfolio i try to reinforce this
idea again by putting in a project that
i did from start to finish
at the very beginning of my portfolio
and you know this is a tiny
project in the world of architecture it
was like 5 000 square feet of renovation
and you know i actually
have projects that i've worked on
that are bigger that are larger scale
um but none of them i've actually done
from start to finish
if i was applying for a large firm
like a stantec or oma or something like
that i would probably try to focus on
completely different strengths like
modeling skills or detailing skills
um so yeah i think you really need to
assess the firm
and
do some strategic thinking when you're
uh making your application if you have
any questions up to this point just let
me know in the comments and i'll try to
get to them as fast as possible
just a few words on the layout and the
format before we get started
just use a standard size like a letter
or legal or tabloid
and if you're applying for a design
position
you should just use indesign it does
look
different from traditional word
and you know it's the first impression
of your work right so
you want to make it inviting you don't
want to make it too cluttered and
you want to make sure that they know
that you know how to use these tools and
give it just clear section headings like
lots of white space
and
yeah just make it easy to read use like
a 11
point font size
probably like 10.5 minimum the format
the most common way to present your
resume is probably the
like reverse chronological
um where you put your most recent
experience first but i've also seen
resumes where like if you don't have too
much relevant work experience or if
you're like looking for a career change
uh you can also
format it in a way that like focuses on
your skill sets today we're just going
to be covering the reverse chronological
format
a typical resume is going to have your
contact info your professional summary
your work experience education and your
skills
and
any other
achievements or awards or activities
professional summary personally
i don't really think it's necessary if
you're gonna put in a cover letter
because the cover letter is gonna
describe a little bit of your background
what you're interested in why you want
to work for the firm and in most cases
people
know why you're applying for the
position
so
yeah i don't know if you don't have
enough space i would say you can cut
that out
um yep and so you cover your
personal details contact info email
phone number address yeah i don't really
think it's necessary nobody's gonna be
mailing you stuff
so yeah i think it's you can leave that
out so summary your objective
this is kind of a two to three sentence
summary of your career and you can place
this at the very top of your resume
and yeah this is just going to give your
employer a very very quick impression of
who you are and what you're looking for
but like i said before if you're
covering this in the cover letter then
this might not be necessary
so in my case
i i put in the cover letter just before
my resume
um in a pdf but i've also done it where
i just send the cover letter in the body
of the email right
so
typically if you know
the name of the principal that you're
emailing and you know that the email is
going directly to someone who's gonna be
looking at your application like the
principal or the partner
then it makes sense to include the cover
letter in the body of the email
but if you know that your application's
gonna be passed around and you don't
know
the name of the person you're sending
the application to
then i would include the cover letter as
a part of the resume
yeah so what i was saying before is that
if you are including a cover letter as a
part of your resume no need to put in
the work summary i don't think it's
necessary but if you are including this
what you can include here is your job
title and your years of experience so
for example
licensed architect aibc with four years
of local experience
you can also
list out like one or two of your
achievements so you can say something
like completed a major renovation in the
city of coquitlam
on time and on budget
and
your desired goal so if you're looking
to
work more in the public sector then you
can say
looking to grow as an architect work on
larger public projects and then you
cover your education where you went to
school and when you went to school
please
please please write the dates of when
you went to school this is very
important before i had a separate
section where i listed all the awards
that i got but i decided to put it all
in this one section so that i could kind
of reduce the amount of text
i put my gpa in here as well
this is probably more important for like
fresh grads but maybe not
once you get a little bit further into
your career and i also listed some other
facts like um being one of three
students who graduate on the accelerated
program and like being on the dean's
list and stuff like that and then you
list your work experience and this is
obviously the most important section of
your resume
you should talk about where you worked
um when you worked there and what your
role was and you can just give a very
brief summary of the highlights of that
role and as well as some of the the
projects that you worked on
and then the portfolio is going to get
into this a little bit more in detail
it's going to talk about your projects
more in detail it's going to show your
design abilities it's going to show your
graphical abilities it's just going to
reinforce
your position as that role a little bit
more
um
yeah and make sure you list everything
in reverse chronological order with your
most recent and the most relevant
experience first
and you know if there's some gaps in
your history
you should be prepared to explain that
most cases they will
ask about that i had a question
from one of my subscribers that was
asking
how you should talk about
lengthy
gap in your employment history and i
actually answered it in one of my q a
sessions so i'll just put the link to
that over here um and then yeah under
achievements you can list out any awards
like i said i decided to bump it into my
education just because a lot of the
awards that i got were from school and
then you can also mention your top soft
and hard skills
so
i kind of separated out the software
just because it's such an important part
of an architecture job you know for a
young architect like knowing certain
software is kind of the difference
between getting hired and not so yeah
like make sure that you know the
software that the firm uses
and usually they'll describe that in the
job description
and under skills i listed out my
architectural skills as well as some of
my non-architectural meta skills you can
also include
languages and hobbies i find languages
to be pretty
helpful especially if you can speak a
language that the firm has a project in
so i know we're looking for people who
can speak dutch because we have a couple
projects there and yeah i think it's
just always an asset to be able to speak
multiple languages
so this was a pretty short video but i
hope it was helpful
and remember your application is just a
way for you to get your foot in the door
your interview is the thing that's gonna
land you the job
so let me know if there's any interest
in interview tips and i can make a video
on that as well
also i just want to add
if you're not successful after your
first few attempts and after you know
following people's advice and following
my advice today
and following the
portfolio tips
don't get too discouraged because
sometimes
it really doesn't have anything to do
with you
or how good you are
usually companies are looking for a very
specific person
and if you don't fit that description
that's fine um if you don't get that job
that's fine
you you don't want to get stuck in a
place where you don't fit in anyways
okay if you haven't watched my video on
how to create a portfolio i would go
watch that it has a step-by-step process
it also has free portfolio templates
so um yeah let me know if you have any
questions yeah i'll see you in the next
video bye oh and good luck
[Music]
you